et si la Russie lançait vraiment une
attaque nucléaire contre l'Ukraine c'est
ce que nous allons voir dans ce nouvel
épisode de facture
la guerre Russo ukrainienne est unique
en effet les menaces de Vladimir Poutine
diffèrent des crises comme celle de Cuba
en 1962 ici il n'est plus question de
bombe dite stratégique qui servent à
détruire complètement l'adversaire mais
plutôt des armes dit tactiques au rayon
des faits plus mesuré et cela change les
règles du jeu les règles du jeu
nucléaire ce sont les règles des échecs
c'est à dire que chaque joueur c'est en
permanence connaît l'état des pièces
leur position il est il est face à
l'échiquier qui est partagé et il est
entendu que le roi ne peut pas être pris
donc l'information est mutuelle le
problème de la crise actuelle avec le
retour du discours sur les armes
nucléaires tactiques en particulier et
bien c'est que l'on change brusquement
non pas simplement de positionnement des
pièces mais de jeux on passe des échecs
au poker et au poker le nucléaire
devient une question de bluff le jeu est
voilé les intentions comme les pièces
sont cachées vous pouvez remporter la
mise avec des cartes de faible et
l'incertitude devient maximal c'est
extrêmement dangereux c'est extrêmement
déstabilisant puisque toute la grammaire
qui avait été apprise dans la douleur
depuis la crise de Cuba en 1962 et bien
devient matière aujourd'hui à
réinterprétation mais alors dans cette
partie de poker menteur existe-t-il un
moyen d'anticiper la suite des
événements il existe un outil c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'échelle de Cannes
cette échelle qui tire son nom derman
Kahn stratège et futurologue américain
ayant inspiré le Docteur Folamour de
kubry comporte 44 étapes elles vont de
la simple crise diplomatique à la guerre
atomique totale le dernier échelon en
passant par la guerre avec des moyens
conventionnels l'utilisation limitée de
l'arme nucléaire sur des cibles
militaires ou bien encore le ciblage
délibéré de certaines villes pour en
faire des exemples bien que rédiger
pendant la guerre froide il est possible
de l'interpréter pour déduire la suite
des opérations
sachez en tout cas que si la Russie
utilise l'arme nucléaire en Ukraine
cette échelle se réduit de moitié on
attaque directement par le 21e barreau
d'emblée l'État qui choisirait d'avoir
recours à l'arme nucléaire se
retrouverait directement en opposition
avec l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale sur 195 pays seul 9
dispose officiellement ou officieusement
de l'arme nucléaire de nombreux pays ont
également renoncé à l'atome militaire
comme le Brésil l'Argentine l'Irak la
Libye ou encore l'Ukraine
on pourrait donc s'attendre à l'adoption
de sanctions contre l'État qui
choisirait d'aller contre cette tendance
du refus du nucléaire
la première option verrait un certain
nombre d'États appelé à une réponse
mesurée mesurée au sens
de ce que cette réponse serait non
nucléaire une réponse sous la forme de
sanction totale sur le plan économique
politique qui ferait de l'État en
question celui qui aurait d'étonné qui
aurait brisé le tabou nucléaire un paria
absolu ce serait une stratégie de non
réponse nucléaire délibérée à un emploi
tactique limité du nucléaire par
l'adversaire donc par cet état ce serait
une politique de Morse sociale
internationale qui s'exercerait
totalement sans limite de durée sur
l'état les citoyens de ce pays dans tous
les domaines sécuritaire économique
sociétaux culturelle quel qu'en soit le
prix avec l'appui de quasiment tous les
membres de la Société internationale les
sanctions pourraient voir leurs effets à
moins de risques cependant si la Russie
estimait que la fuite en avant nucléaire
serait sa seule porte de sortie à ce
moment là les Occidentaux pourraient
choisir de rentrer eux aussi dans la
danse atomique la réponse nucléaire elle
serait finalement
décidé pour éviter la piraterie
stratégique du fait accompli pour éviter
que le chantage ne paye finalement des
états s'interrogeraient à ce moment-là
donc sur sur l'opportunité d'une riposte
de même nature et de passerait à
l'action
que va-t-il se passer ensuite il faut
comprendre que les premières frappes
atomiques pourraient cibler non pas des
infrastructures militaires ou des lieux
stratégiques il s'agirait de frapper un
lieu inhabité comme par exemple la mer
Noire qui est située également en dehors
des frontières de la Russie si ces
attaques ne suffisent pas à faire
asseoir les belligérants autour de la
table des négociations alors on continue
à grimper les échelons la guerre
resterait localisée au théâtre des
opérations mais les cibles militaires ne
seraient plus épargnées on a atteint le
23e barreau si l'on continue plus loin
alors la guerre n'est plus localisée à
l'Ukraine et les zones géographiquement
proches mais s'étendra directement au
sanctuaire des belligérants la folie
nucléaire selon l’échelle de Cannes
conduirait alors à des frappes sur des
lieux inhabités situés à l’intérieur des
territoires des États souverains comme
des chaînes de montagne ou des déserts
c'est le 26e barreau les échelons
d'après c'est la guerre nucléaire
commencent l'imagine c'est-à-dire des
attaques contre des bases des centres
stratégiques ou des villes mais
détailler la suite des événements avec
précision donne non seulement la nausée
mais relève également d'un travail de
fiction sachez seulement que l'échelle
de Cannes vise la suite des événements
en deux parties la première qui concerne
les étapes 27 à 38 concerne une guerre
qui se concentrerait sur des cibles
militaires plus on grimpe plus les
frappes sont massives et nombreuses
enfin la suite c'est à dire les échelons
39 à 44 concernerait des cibles avec
pour but de détruire complètement la ou
les nations adverses le 44e barreau
c'est-à-dire le dernier correspondrait à
une guerre dite spasmodique ou plus
personne ne contrôlerait plus rien des
officiers isolés pourraient eux-mêmes
décider de frapper puisque la chaîne de
commandement n'existe tout simplement
plus
malgré les plans des stratèges malgré
les doctrines qui servent peut-être plus
à nous rassurer qu'à nous protéger une
question demeure jusqu'à quel échelon la
guerre qui bouleverse le monde depuis le
24 février monta-t-elle Vladimir Poutine
a fait un pari ce pari ne peut plus être
gagné sur le plan tactique coopératif
mais les armes nucléaires peuvent
éventuellement lui permettre de ne pas
perdre ce pari sur le plan stratégique
et si l'effondrement conventionnel
russes s'accentue éventuellement et bien
la tentation d'emploi sera de plus en
plus fort
[Musique]